uh good afternoon everyone I'm very
excited to announce uh last and final
keynote Jeff Leake we are particularly
lucky to get Jeff leak as a keynote
speaker right now because he's in the
middle of a cross-country move to start
a new position as a VP and chief data
officer at the Fred Hutchinson Institute
for cancer research
[Applause]
so uh Jeff is uh famous for very many
things but uh two in particular uh that
I wanted to talk about the first is
along with Roger ping and Brian careful
Jeff taught really like the first data
science mooc which introduced R to
literally millions of people which is
pretty amazing
[Applause]
the the other thing I love about Jeff is
that him and I uh disagree on a few
things and one of the things in
particular several years ago he wrote a
blog post why I don't use ggplot2
but what I love about uh Jeff's riding
is he articulates his position so
clearly like even as I was reading the
article I was like nothing along yeah
yeah that makes sense
so uh please join me welcoming Jeff
Leake
thanks very much and thanks Hadley I
know you've been saving that up for a
minute
um I will say that I have become a
ggplot2 convert since then uh so yes yes
I'm not even playing to the audience
there yeah
um so I'm very excited to be here today
to talk to you about data trail which is
an effort that we've been uh running in
Baltimore for the last four or five
years to build inclusive community-based
data science uh education and I hope
that you all uh be excited to go back
into your communities and also build
programs and and connect to your
communities
one thing I wanted to start off with
though is uh I wanted to just say I'm so
excited to be in a room with all of you
I've seen tons of people that I haven't
seen for two and a half years uh the
very last conference I went to in
January 2020 before this one was our
studio conf in San Francisco I then got
on an airplane flew back to Baltimore
and the world ended
uh I know that all of us over the last
two and a half years have gone through
many many things they're both individual
and Collective and I just want to
express the joy that I feel to be back
together with people and back with the
art community and especially this
amazing community that the band formally
called our studio has put together
and so
um I'm really excited about that and I
just wanted to express my gratitude both
for the invitation to speak here today
and to the community that's been built
all of you to coming out and sticking
around for the last talk
before I go any further I also wanted to
make sure I thank the people that did
all the real important work
um this is the data trail core team
um uh Ashley Johnson Simone Sawyer Ed
Sabatino Devon person and and uh Ashley
and Davon are actually here today and if
they could stand up and wave they're
somewhere in the audience there they are
back there
[Music]
um anything good you hear anything good
you here is definitely because of them
uh anything silly or misguided is due to
me
um this is the kind of project that
can't be done by just a couple of people
there's been a huge community of people
that have helped us over the years
developed the data trail program and I
just wanted to uh say that we're so
grateful to all the people that helped
out
um one of the things I wanted to talk a
little bit about is my own journey to
where I am here today as Hadley
mentioned I'm in the middle of a move to
take a big exciting new job right near
my family which I'm really excited about
but I didn't start there as none of us
did I started off as just a nerdy kid
from a very small town in Idaho
um this is an embarrassing picture that
usually other people show in a
presentation
um
but how did that happen how did I go
from Nerdy kid in Idaho to to where I am
today and I imagine we all had a similar
kind of Journey right we had to know
that this was a field which some are
just discovering now some discovered a
long time ago we had to have access to
the equipment and the training and the
connections to be able to be in a room
here today
um but more importantly than that we had
I had to have help this is not something
that I did on my own I had to be lifted
up at various points in my career for my
undergrad advisor Jim Powell to my grad
advisor John story to Giovanni
parmigiani who recruited me to Baltimore
by saying do you want to live near your
wife to uh Rafa irizari who was my main
uh faculty Mentor in my early years and
many many other people who have worked
with me
um just like me I'm sure you feel the
same way that there are people that have
helped you out in your life and so I
wanted to just take a minute because
we're all here together to turn to your
neighbor and maybe tell them about
somebody that helped you along your way
we're gonna just take a minute here and
I'd like you to tell somebody about one
of your mentors somebody who helped you
out when you had a moment of need so I'm
just going to give a brief pause and
make it a little interactive please talk
to your neighbor
if you're online on Discord you can talk
the same way
this is awesome
all right
I know that this conversation could last
a long time
and I hope you'll continue that
conversation later
and I hope it reminded you of somebody
that helped you along the way because
the data trail program we're building is
about helping other people
and so one of the key things that we
realized that I think everybody
recognizes is that Talent is equally
distributed so these are some young
people from our second cohort of data
trail scholars in East Baltimore these
are folks that grew up around there and
are incredibly talented young people
and there's an important thing that uh
that even though the talent is equally
distributed opportunity isn't always so
this is data from The Economic
Opportunity Atlas and it says that if
you were born and grew up in this
neighborhood the median family income
when you get to age 34 is 18 000 a year
so that whole neighborhood
even though it's right next to a
multi-billion dollar Medical Institution
doesn't have access to the same career
opportunities that say I did when I grew
up out in Idaho
and it's not just Baltimore where this
is true if you look at the Economic
Opportunity Atlas where I'm going in
Seattle Pittsburgh Chicago uh Tampa Bay
New York City no matter where you look
there are these opportunity deserts and
so how do we create opportunity and
these opportunities as deserts how do we
actively go out and promote
opportunities for folks that grew up
there
and it's not just economic it's not just
an economic calculation it's also a
health calculation I was in a school of
Public Health I'm moving to a Cancer
Center I care a lot about health
this is a plot it doesn't look like real
data but it is real data this is a plot
of income percentile on the x-axis and
on the y-axis is life expectancy you've
got one line for a female one line for
male and you can see that there's like
near perfect correlation between how
much money your parents made and your
life expectancy on average in the
population which is kind of incredible
education is still the best treatment we
have to cure the problem of lack of
opportunity
this is a plot that shows how much your
parents made on that x-axis and on the
y-axis is how much you make after going
to different types of schools each color
represents a different type of school
and the lines are relatively flat which
means if you get into one of those
schools you have a very good chance of
moving up economically
but the challenge is you can't always
get in
so this is a similar plot this is
colleges each dot is a college on the
x-axis is How likely you are to get into
that College from on a scale from zero
to 100 if your parent based on your
parents income
and on the y-axis is How likely you are
to be in the top quartile of uh of
um income after completing College there
so places like Johns Hopkins where I
used to be at have very low access if
your parents didn't have a lot of money
it's unlikely you're going to get into
that college but if you go there you're
going to have a very good chance of
having a high economic return
and so you can actually calculate this
for every College you can say multiply
the probability you get in if you're
from the lowest quintile of income times
the probability you'll be in the highest
income if you get it once you get out
and that can be what we call Mobility
rate this is a calculation developed by
some economists
and so the best generators of mobility
in the United States are typically large
public institutions community colleges
technical colleges that produce the
highest level of economic mobility in
our country
and they're driven by access so you can
see that the success rates don't have to
be in the high 90s to be these are the
very top colleges in the U.S and it's
driven by how accessible that education
is
and so we're all here because we love
data science we love R we love python we
love all the other languages and it's a
high growth and wage job in uh category
and so how do we get more people to have
access to this
as Hadley mentioned we've been teaching
massive online open courses about data
science for a long time and they've now
enrolled more than 10 million people
across the world
and these programs can lead to Big
income gains so here I'm showing a plot
on the access axis is the cost of the
program and I've got graduate school
undergraduate associate's degree and on
the y-axis is the increase in income
post program and for one of our data
science sequences you get nearly the
same amount of income boost as you would
for a college or Advanced degree even
for a much lower cost so that seems
pretty exciting and originally we were
thinking okay this is how we generate
this Mobility at scale
but as not just us but many many people
have noted Coursera classes boot camps
those sorts of things they tend to
benefit the already well educated most
of the people taking these programs are
actually already have bachelor's degrees
master's degrees professional degrees
and a career transitioning so we're not
really generating active access for the
people that the mobility rate applies to
and so what we try to do is can we
create opportunities for the folks that
aren't taking the massive online at cope
and courses who haven't been introduced
to R via these scalable programs
and unless I say that we're the only
people thinking about this there are a
ton of amazing I've been to talks today
from openscapes to you know met amazing
people from various parts of the world
we got our ladies we've got data
carpentry the bioconductor team so many
people that are also trying to do this
to try to lift people up through the
power of data Science Education and data
science opportunities
but the reality is there are significant
barriers to entry I showed this graph a
minute ago for myself but it applies to
anyone who wants to get into data
science you have to know about data
science you have to have the income
security to participate you have to have
access to a computer programs
instruction connections the right jobs
it's a lot
so how do we take these barriers down
one by one
so first you have to know about data
science and so the way that we've
addressed that problem with our program
is we actually go out into the community
and we partner with community-based
education associations like historic
East Baltimore Community Action
Coalition and the Heart smiles
who train young people to get their
their High School diplomas who train
them to get Technical Training and we
teach them about the opportunities that
are there in data science we partner
with them to recruit students for our
program
then how do we address the computer
so this is the thing that maybe kicked
off all of this for me I love
Chromebooks and you can get a Chromebook
for 450 we've seen the power of this
with education over the last couple of
years with the pandemic
and it turns out that you can be a data
scientist on a Chromebook this is where
again our studio and posit have been a
major player in what we've been able to
do by creating our studio Cloud we were
one of the first programs to jump onto
that platform so that you can do all of
your data science work directly on the
cloud it's such an incredible tool and
I'm so grateful that we've been able to
use that to help train people
and so you can be a data scientist on a
Chromebook you can use Google slides and
Google Sheets and you can use our studio
and you can teach people how to do it
and they don't need a MacBook Pro to be
a data scientist
there's also barriers to entry you know
if you need to buy a MacBook Pro it
costs you three thousand dollars if you
only if your family only made eighteen
thousand dollars last year you can't
participate in a program like this
so with funding from Johns Hopkins
originally later from the able
Foundation we actually pay the students
to complete the courses so as they
finish our massive online open courses
they earn money so that they can
participate in it like a part-time job
thank you yeah thanks to Abel thanks to
Johns Hopkins
we also need access to the right kind of
instruction and the appropriate and
programs
so here's where R really shines why
would we use R we've I get asked this
question all the time we built our
entire training program around R I know
that there's also python people here and
we love python 2 but we built our whole
program around R and I get asked a lot
why we did that
and the reason why is we wanted to
minimize the time to Magic
so with just a few lines of code are
marked down with just a few lines of
code can put a website up on the web
that's interactive that you can show off
to your friends and to your family
with things like big The Big R query
package and DB player you can connect to
massive databases and analyze huge
collections of data with just a few
lines of code
and with things like shiny Flex
dashboard shiny dashboards knows you can
also write just as few lines of code
here it's like 34 lines of code that
creates an interactive nhanes website
so with with minimizing time to Magic we
can train people very quickly to do
incredible things
and then we can build a program around
it we can build a community around it
that helps support people as they go
through and they learn how to do data
science we do this on Basecamp you could
also do it on slack or any other
community uh building platform but there
has to be both an online and an
in-person component
so then the last part is you have to
think about okay say we have a training
program so we've trained them to do it
we've built it in our then they need
access to connections they need to be
able to actually get a job
and so here we can again Leverage The R
Community the the people here in the
audience today to help make connections
between the young people that we're
training and the broader community and
opportunities that are out there
and this ecosystem really works we've
had 80 success rate in our Johns Hopkins
pilot that I'm going to tell you a
little bit about at completing the
training just to give you some idea
massive online open courses in general
the completion rate hovers somewhere
between two percent and five percent so
80 completion rate for this massive
online open sequence is an incredible
Testament to the will and intelligence
of the people that we're training in the
community
after they after they finished the
training program though we want to put
them into opportunities that can help
change their lives
and so there are their reality is there
are significant barriers to entry to
these jobs but we've partnered with
programs that support
internships that represent a soft
Landing place we teach people data
science in 16 weeks that is not a lot of
time to learn data science and learn how
to be a data scientist so we partner
with programs like Urban Alliance and we
have a couple of people here Chaz and
LaShonda from Urban Alliance I don't
know where they're sitting but they're
also in the audience here today over
there and they're helping us build
internship programs that support the
long component of training that's
developing the soft skills developing
the approach to work that will let them
be in these careers long term
so I'm going to tell you a little bit
now about our pilot that we ran in
Baltimore
this is what the whole pilot has felt
like
we started this off with just an idea
and absolutely no program and so at
every turn it's felt like we're barely
getting the train tracks together in
time to be able to continue to run the
program
so this is how it started in February
2018 we started developing content for
our data science training program we met
with hubcap historic East Baltimore
Community Action Coalition in April of
2018 and we told them we were developing
a program and we were excited about
working with them they got very excited
and they said can we start tomorrow
remember we had started developing our
program in February it was April
and so they said okay we'll give you a
little time we'll start in May
we had to develop this much content
between February and May so we're
talking 12 courses to cover everything
from how to use computers to how do you
organize projects to the Tidy verse to
written and oral communication to how to
get a job
12 12 courses in five months
so this was me I was a little stressed I
was worried that we wouldn't be able to
do it
but fortunately we had some really
incredible help so at the time there are
two people I particularly want to call
out Shannon Ellis and abizar hadavan who
were post-docs in my group one was an
economist working on studying how the
outcomes of these massive online open
courses and one was a geneticist
but they pitched in and they said we can
build this whole program in that much
time
so they assembled this collaborative
team and on GitHub using our markdown we
built this entire program in that much
time
we did have some challenges along the
way though as we were building the
program the courses like getting and
cleaning data were being updated because
new packages would come out
so this is a plot on the x-axis's time
thousands of R scripts after the start
of a program and on the y-axis is the
usage of different packages there's one
that kind of stands out and that's
because right in the middle of when
we're developing these courses D plier
comes out rendering half of our program
totally valueless and we have to start
from scratch thanks Hadley
so what we had to do is regenerate all
of our materials and we now pay very
careful attention to what the rstudio
and uh posit folks are doing on their
GitHub repos as we're developing courses
we built this program and so now we were
ready to start training people so we
thought well let's start May 1st how
long does the program last
they asked me we'd never run it before
in fact we just built the program
I don't know how long the program lasts
let's call it 12 weeks
so I told them we were going to do it in
12 weeks Shannon abizar and I said okay
we're going to finish it by August 31st
despite us still having to fix up
courses all the bugs are two pilot
candidates finished in about 14 weeks 16
weeks sorry
so that was pretty incredible we took
two young people from headcack they'd
never heard of data science before we
got them through an entire 12 course
move sequence they both finished it was
awesome
now they've finished the data science
training program and we realized we got
to get them a job
and so there's a bit of a challenge that
we ran into that you may have run into
sometimes in your search for jobs
this is the rules and responsibilities
you may experience that you need to do
once you get on the job and this might
be the job experience they're asking for
we saw that a lot we saw that there were
jobs that we knew that our graduates
could perform but were not necessarily
advertised in the right way
moreover we ran into the Fair Labor and
standards act and I learned more about
the legal requirements around employment
than I would care to repeat but the
basic idea is that because they're not
computer scientists they actually write
text and they write prose and things
like that they don't qualify to be
exempt employees unless they have a
bachelor's degree so we need them to be
hourly data scientist jobs
which it turns out a few companies have
but many don't
so we're this close
we train these young people they're
brilliant they finish the program but we
can't quite get them in uh to the finish
line
so what are we going to do about this
how are we going to actually get them to
the point where they can be employed and
they can move to a different place in
their life
so I did what anyone would do I called a
friend of mine an old family friend who
was a consultant for IBM and I said
let's start a consulting company and so
he and I started a consulting company
and we would do data science Consulting
work for companies all around the
country
we would do them for Fortune 500
companies for small companies small mom
and pop shops and all of the data
science work that was being done was
being done by graduates of our program
that we were hiring from the training
program
this worked great they had graduates did
an amazing job we were able to do it but
we were a bootstraps bespoke data
science consulting company and
ultimately that's not the way that this
is going to work going forward
so the next part of our story is we
brought on Ashley Johnson who's here
today as a core member of our team as a
program manager for data trail and she
managed through a lot of hard work Blood
Sweat and Tears to get our HR systems at
Johns Hopkins which is a massive
organization that where HR does not move
quickly to create a new job code so that
we could hire people at Johns Hopkins
specifically with the credentials from
our program this is an incredible
Testament to Ashley's patients and
Brilliance getting this through the
system and it allowed us to hire Dave on
person who's a graduate of our program
to be the main ta for all of our future
training cohorts
this kind of work has to be done by
Advocates within an organization this
isn't data science work this is the hard
blocking and tackling that needs to be
done by each and every one of us if we
want to build new opportunities where
there weren't opportunities before build
new Bridges
we have this phrase that we always say
when we're building this program hard
things are hard to do when you want to
make a big change in the way the world
works it's not going to be easy it's
going to be hard and that means it's
going to be hard to do but it's worth
doing even though it is hard
so I think I'm going to take another
brief pause
and I'm going to have all of you think
about some time you accomplish something
something that was really hard that
you're really proud that you did even
though it took a lot of work and it was
kind of painful tell your neighbor about
it we'll give you another couple of
minutes and then we'll come back
all right
we'll jump back into it
all right I'm stoked about this
everybody was very excited to tell each
other about their accomplishments that's
great I'm excited about it
hopefully I'll get to hear some of them
later from some of you
so again hard things are hard but
they're worth doing as you all just were
telling each other about something that
you were really proud of but it took a
lot of work to do
so it's exciting to be a part of those
things it's exciting to be and
compelling to be part of something that
feels like it's really important even if
it takes a lot of work
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
the impact of this program and what it's
meant to the people in the community and
to us
so first I wanted to mention Devon who's
here today again he's I can't remember
where he is but Devon is our lead there
he is all right
Devon is our curriculum lead for data
trail he's a graduate of the program an
incredible guy I knew Devon was going to
be the right guy for our program when we
had a dinner at our house for all the
data trail uh trainees he came to my
house and he spent the whole dinner
teaching my at the time eight-year-old
son had to play chess uh unfortunately
that's bad for me because now I get beat
all the time at chess
but it was a great Testament to like the
incredible talent that he has for
helping people learn how to do things so
it's so great to have him as part of the
program
another incredible part of this Pro uh
program is that one of our graduates
while working at problem forward worked
on an HBO documentary called the slow
hustle if you any of you have seen it if
not you should definitely go out and see
it they did a bunch of analysis of the
historic redlining in Baltimore's
community that prevented people from
buying houses in different communities
within Baltimore it's quite a famous
problem around the world but in
Baltimore it's particularly transparent
how big a problem it was and so was
credited actually in the movie credits
for their analysis of uh the data that
showed this redlining was really
unbelievable effort that was made by a
data trail graduate
thank you yeah
and so this is an example of a quote we
we collect quotes from all the people
that come from the program and so it
says it gave me a new Direction and
Tommy you can be different Go a
different route than your parents not
always hanging on to what Society tells
you you can follow your own protocol
so it just gave me a sense like a new
world or a new field and a new life that
I got to see
it's such an incredible thing to be a
mentor it's such an incredible thing to
be a person that makes a connection to a
new field to a new opportunity and it's
been incredibly rewarding to see that
happen not just for us but watch it
scale as Devon makes connections for
people as Candace makes connections for
people as Ashley makes connections for
people
but we did learn some lessons along the
way
I mentioned that we were a train that
was constantly trying to take things off
the track this was almost all due to the
fact that I'm a biostatistician by
training I don't know the first thing
about building a community organization
and had to learn over and over and over
again things that people who work in the
field have known for a long time we
learned those by listening by paying
attention by spending time in those
communities but they're important and
hard lessons
one of the most important things we
learned is that I mean here at a data
science conference at our conference but
data science is actually the easy part
of all of this the young people that go
through our program are bright they're
good at computers pretty soon they're
teaching us about data science that's
not the hard part the hard part is
everything around it all the stuff that
comes up in somebody's life you know
housing falling through not being able
to get Transportation not having access
to the resources not having access to
the connections of people that can hook
you up with a job or an opportunity
those are the things that really take
work to make something like this happen
the other thing that we learned is that
building trust takes takes time you know
we're we're working in a community we're
working you know we come from Johns
Hopkins at the time now from the hutch
you know and we're making these
connections to community-based
organizations who've been working in
those communities for a long time but
we're new you know we we're not we're
not part of that Community yet and it
takes time and it takes effort and it
takes being there all the time
consistently to be able to build that
trust so that you can actually build a
relationship that will last and will
create people that move on to the next
step
you know it's hard to tell somebody you
just met what's really going on one of
the things that's always the biggest
challenge in our program is getting
people to ask questions it's
intimidating to ask questions when
you're starting something new it's a
it's a scary thing to admit you don't
know something and so it's an important
part of the program to build trust to
build those connections so that people
can comfortably ask you what's what's
wrong what I tell you what's wrong ask
you for help it's one of the things I
appreciate to an incredible degree about
the community here is that we're open to
questions that when people email you or
tweet at you or send you a GitHub
request you answer those questions
politely and kindly and with compassion
it means the world to people who are
just starting out
and we also need to be able to scale
employment and internships our original
idea was basically born out of panic I
hadn't really thought through how we're
going to get people jobs at the end of
this training program we started that's
my fault
we needed something a little better than
just starting a random consulting
company
and so we need to be able to scale those
uh employment opportunities and those
internship opportunities and this is
where Partnerships with organizations
that know what they're doing is critical
so we've been working with the urban
Alliance who has a whole program and a
whole system for managing internships
for young people who come from
communities like the one we're trying to
serve
and so we're partnering with them to be
able to run these internships in a
long-term and sustainable way
we also need advocates
so one of the things that we've realized
as we're going through this program is
the thing that problem forward did it
wasn't that it was a data science
consulting company it wasn't that it was
related to the training program it was
that we could Advocate on behalf of
young people who come out of these
communities who are talented individuals
who have credentials that maybe look a
little different who maybe don't have
all of the background that other people
might have when they're first starting
out but that are really talented and
could be spectacular if just given a
chance so within all organizations we
need those Advocates and those Advocates
have to be people like you people like
me people who have opportunity already
and can reach out and try to support
somebody else as they go through that
same Journey that we all went through
that I had to go through when I came
from Idaho to get to here
and the other thing we need is mutually
intensive learning it's been an
incredible experience I think for both
sides both people that are coming out of
the training program and the mentors and
teachers and hiring Partners to learn
about each other to learn about the
things we do well you know I don't know
the first thing about Instagram and Tick
Tock and all that kind of stuff but I'm
learning I'm learning that's how we're
getting into new communities and I'm
learning that from the people that are
in the training program so I think that
there's a a way that we can learn from
each other it's not just teaching data
science in One Direction it's also
learning in the other direction as well
and that mutually intensive learning can
really develop a relationship that lasts
a long time
so what's the future what's the future
of data trail we've I told you about the
pilot I told you about what we were
we're in a great place with data trail
now and we're just starting to think
about the future and how do we scale
this up
so our data trail model has three big
components now
there's colleges and universities or
training Partners in general they
provide tutors and educational support
then there's hiring Partners or mentors
they provide the mentors and
opportunities for the people once they
finish the training program
and then we have non-profit and
community-based partners who do the hard
work of supporting the whole person
because when you're doing a training
program and you're coming from a
community that doesn't have a lot of
resources
small things can cause big problems if
you don't have the support you need to
get through the training program and so
the three groups working together can
really provide that infrastructure that
unlike underlying infrastructure that
gives somebody the opportunity to come
from a community without a lot of
opportunity into a place where they can
be a leader in the field
so in Baltimore we do this with the
Johns Hopkins data science lab providing
the tutoring and support so we've got
Candace savinen here who's from the job
was it the Johns Hopkins data science
lab is now at the Fred Hutch data
science lab I don't know where she is
but she could stand up but she's helping
to provide the tutoring and support with
Davon
um we have mentors and opportunities
that we're building out with Urban
Alliance
and then we have incredible non-profit
and community-based Partnerships built
in Baltimore that provides social and
life support to the young people who are
going through our programs so that if
something comes up they can get that
support they need to stay in the program
to stick with it to get the opportunity
that they're going after
so this is how our program works now
from January to June we were recruiting
young people we're getting into schools
we're providing content online we're
trying to get people excited about data
science
and then from June to September we're
doing our training program we're
actually running the data trail courses
they're going through they're getting
paid as they complete the courses and
they're finishing the program and we're
also recruiting mentors we're recruiting
the people that are ultimately going to
hire and mentor and manage the young
people in their first opportunity
then from September to June they do an
internship this is supported by Urban
Alliance and this is a 10 hour a week
internship where they get paid it's
virtual and they get mentorship a couple
of hours a week from a mentor at a
hiring company or partner
this is how the program works now
and so there's an opportunity for you to
get involved with us at data trail if
you're interested
there's two different ways
one is
the more heavy duty way which is start
your own data trail in your own
community
and the other way is to hire or Mentor
data trail graduates from our program
so I'm going to start with starting your
own data trail program we talked a
little bit about doing hard things and
we did a hard thing to set this thing up
and we've paved a lot of the ground for
you
so if you're interested in starting your
own data trail Community you can reach
out to Ashley Johnson to myself and we
can provide you with a lot of the
background and materials you need to
build this program in your community we
can provide startup documents
relationship agreements we can give you
information on how to get funded we
provide free courses so you can access
them and train people in data science
and then we provide access to the data
trail community so you can talk to the
people who are building it in Baltimore
and around the country
this I'm very excited because the first
data trail franchise has started already
so Madu and Melanie contacted us they're
at Mount Sinai health system in New York
City and they were really excited about
data trail
and the two of them set up a data trail
franchise that's running completely
independently in New York and is now on
its second cohort of graduates placing
people in the medical health system
placing them at jobs around New York
City it's amazing to see how just a
couple of committed people could have
such an incredible impact on the lives
of young people in their community and
I'm so impressed with the work that
Maddie and Melanie are doing
yeah it's awesome
so the other way you can get involved is
to hire a mentor so we're working with
Urban Alliance as I mentioned and
there's two ways that you can do this
you could hire data trail graduates into
your pro into your company if you have
internships that you want to support
it's part-time internships they're
remote paid internships and they can be
supported by Urban Alliance and data
trail in other words we support them on
the technical side an urban Alliance
supports them on the soft skills side
I'm incredibly excited to announce that
posit has committed to host two of these
interns this fall from our data trail
cohort which is an amazing opportunity
and thank you so much
the other cool opportunity and this I'm
also wildly excited about is that you
can mentor data trail graduates as an
open source developer
so we could place people directly into
companies but there's also an incredible
opportunity for our data trail grads to
make an impact on the open source and
open science community
and so the idea here is we get
philanthropic and corporate funding to
pay for the internship and then we will
recruit mentors from the open source
Community to work on their projects and
so posit again has committed incredibly
to fund one of these this fall if you're
an open source developer that's looking
for somebody to work with you on your
project and you're looking for a
talented young person you should come
and talk to us after the event
and then the able Foundation has also
agreed to fund one more this fall from
our training program and that represents
our entire training cohort is going to
get funded this year and we're excited
about building this over time
so if you have an idea about a program
that you if you want to either Mentor a
student this uh fall or you want to
start thinking about next fall get in
touch I've got the email addresses up
here of Chaz Ackley who's the urban
urban Alliance partner the director of
the Baltimore office and Ashley Johnson
who's the director of the data trail
program in Baltimore and you can reach
out to either of them or to me if you're
excited about mentoring a data trail
grad
I'd like to finish though talking about
not just data trail because this is a
cool opportunity and we would love to
work with all of you but you can also do
it in any other way that you feel like I
think just bringing it back to what I
said at the beginning of the talk
this is an incredible opportunity to be
together to build community together and
I think that what posit in our studio
have done is is just an amazing way to
make us all feel part of the same
community
one of the things that uh we should do
is help each other whether that's
through data trail or through openscapes
or our ladies or data carpentry or any
other program that you're excited about
and there's this quote that I love I I
emailed my undergrad advisor when I
first got my very first faculty job and
I told them I was so excited about it I
got to live near my wife I got to live
in Baltimore I got to do my dream job
and he wrote me back that he was really
glad to hear and he said mentorship is a
debt you can't pay off I had some
mentors who helped me when I was young
and I could never pay it off to them I
can only pay it forward to other people
and so he said thank you for helping me
pay off my debt and I feel like we're
all in this room oh a debt of gratitude
to all of the people that have helped us
be here to get today and whatever way
you choose to express that I hope you'll
think about ways that you can pay off
your or pay forward your debt
there's almost nothing more rewarding
than this it's been an incredible
journey and I think that the people here
today the data trail folks the urban
Alliance folks the heart Smiles folks uh
the hebcack folks they're all here to
say that this is the one of the most
rewarding things you can do is create
opportunities for young people
with that I'll thank you and at the
conclusion of the talk after this is all
over I'm going to be hanging out up here
in front with Ashley with Chaz with Dave
on with Candace if you're excited about
mentoring or talking about data trail
please come and hang out and talk and
we'd love to get to talk to you thank
you very much for your attention
thanks Jeff now we uh engage in light
Ben to uh for light dancer live band for
one to two minutes until uh people ask
questions and have a chance to upvote
them so late banter about ggplot2 yeah
sure I'm I'm glad I got my digs in
before yeah that was that was a good
investment I feel like that's the only
reason I got the invitation was so
Hadley got to say that
I was actually reading through like
there's been a few you also I went on
Tidy data that wasn't really like
against tidy data but I was not against
no that was like very much like
these are some use cases or it's like
not great for and yeah it was right yeah
oh man I'm getting all the grapes
somebody's seeing me with the question
please
okay we do have one question one
question one just one to save you uh are
the mentoring opportunities only
available in Baltimore no these are
remote online mentorship opportunities
so if you are an open source developer
and are excited about mentoring a young
person that it's going to get paid for
by the able Foundation it's going to get
paid for deposit so we're good you just
get an awesome mentee to work with you
for a year so if you're a open source
developer anywhere please reach out
cool
and the next question how have the
program graduates been doing long term
how are things yeah they're they're all
over the place they're doing uh
everything from data science jobs but
the kind of cool thing about it is you
know people like Davon is working with
us we've got other young people that are
working in data science jobs one is
converted to python which is great but
you know
I won't say that too loudly uh but then
there's also some people that just took
the training and then went a different
direction in what they cared about I
think one of the cool things about the
program is we're catching young people
at a really formative time of their life
so it's 17 to 23 or so and I'm sure you
all remember you didn't exactly know
what you wanted to do when you were 17
and so data science could be cool for a
while and they learned some stuff from
us and then they maybe go apply it so
you know the skills they learn somewhere
else and so we have some people that end
up in data science careers some people
that go back to school some people that
end up like doing something totally
different but kind of leveraging the the
training
um but we keep in touch with all of them
and so uh you know I'm always texting
with with people that have graduated
from the program and it's it's cool to
see that Community build over time so
yeah now what are some of the challenges
you faced in terms of both kind of like
buy-in and just like raising awareness
of the program
yeah so I think that I tried to
highlight a couple of the key issues but
like there's there's been a a whole
collection of issues in in doing this
everything from you know HR problems to
legal problems to bureaucratic problems
to like building data science program
problems and I think the the core
message though is that
um the thing that helps most is to think
about the target at the end so our goal
is to help young people get
opportunities sometimes that's by
building a data science program but
sometimes it's by Ashley and I go into a
million HR meetings to try to create a
new job uh code and so I think thinking
about that Target like what you're
trying to create at the end gives you a
lot of leeway to to do all the things
you need to do and then being flexible
about learning new things I think that's
that's been the hard thing for me
definitely I didn't know the first thing
about you know a biostatistician what do
I know about any of that but I'm
learning over time and I feel like
having smart people I work with helps
what about plans as you transition to
the hutch yeah so we're getting ready to
be able to run the program in Seattle so
I'm excited about that
um and then it's running in New York we
have a couple of other Ambitions about
starting in a couple of other cities I
can't announce quite yet but we're that
we're going to start soon and so really
now we're at the stage where we're
excited about scaling it out and so it's
been running in Baltimore for a few
years it's successful in Baltimore and I
think it's the kind of program that can
very easily run in a number of cities
around the US that I highlighted and so
we're really in this phase of trying to
get connected to the right people who
are excited about running those programs
so awesome thanks Jeff I really and that
was like just amazing uplifting keynote
so thank you so much appreciate it
foreign